نحن الان في هذا الحي السكني في قلب مدينه
اكراماتورس هذا المكان الذي استهدف وفقا
للسلطات الاوكرانيه بصاروخ الروسي من نوع
اسكندر استهدف هذا المكان وفقا لحاكم
مقاطعه هناك ثلاثه من القتلى ونحو 20
جريحا ثلاثه منهم اصابته خطيره وبالتالي
ربما يكون عدد القتلى مرجح للارتفاع بسبب
هذه الحالات الخطيره عمال الانقاذ ما
زالوا يعملون على رفع الانقاذ في محاوله
للعثور ربما على ناجي او على جثث تحت هذه
الانقاذ نحن تحدثنا مع عمال الانقاذ
وتحدثوا لنا عن احتمال وجود ربما شخص او
شخصين تحت هذه الانقاب ولكن العمل ما زال
مستمر وهم غير متاكدين من ذلك طبعا بسبب
قوه هذا القصف تضررت العديد من المباني
هناك مبنى دمر بشكل كامل واكثر من ثمانيه
مباني دمرت بشكل جزئي لكن طبعا الضر
العديد من المنازل في محيط هذه المنطقه
كما تشاهدون وربما ان نوافذ العديد من هذه
المنازل قد تضررت بسبب هذا الانفجار القوي
في مركز المدينه بالمناسبه والذي لا يبعد
ربما سوى نحو 500 متر عن مركز المحافظه عن
مبنى حاكم هذه المدينه الرئيس المسكي قال
بان هذا هو الواقع اليومي للمدن
الاوكرانيه نعم هذه المدينه تستهدف بشكل
مستمر بالامس استهدفت احدى المقابر فيها
مدينه سلافي القريبه ايضا استهدفت بالامس
وتم تدمير احد المصانع مصانع الاثاث
المغلقه ايضا دروسكوب ستهدفت بالامس
وبالتالي يبدو ان مسلسل استهداف هذه المدن
القريبه من الجبهه الشرقيه يبقى مستمرا
امر لا في الجزيره كراماتورز